scp-682 vs scp-536  the hard to destroy reptile seems to  ignore the laws of physics most of the  time but how will he fare when the  foundation uses the scp-536 chamber to  manipulate the laws of physics around it  scp-680 containment tank was moved into  the 536 chamber the speed of light  fundamental charge and nuclear force  were increased progressively over time  the chamber was utterly annihilated in  seconds but even when the process was  done and 682 was reduced to one percent  of its normal size it was still alive  one of the researchers lost it from the  frustration and began turning all the  dials to torture the creature he was  removed from the cross testing room but  was later forgiven for his indiscretions  with his supervisor noting that he would  have done the same seeing as at times  682 seemed almost like it enjoyed the  process